Some people might think that actors have it
easy, without realizing that every time you
see them playing dead, taking a dive, fending
off live birds or their co-stars, it means
they actually had to do it over and over,
for days on end.
That kind of stress can lead to tears, fights,
and sometimes, the actor threatening to abandon
the movie completely.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Movie Scenes That
Almost Made Actors Quit.
12 Rounds
John Cena may look like someone who’s not
afraid of anything, just don’t expect him
to take you rock climbing.
The pro wrestler turned action star admits
that he has a fear of heights, and while making
2009’s 12 Rounds he had to shoot a scene
where he repels down the side of a building
and then dangles from the rope in mid-air.
On a DVD extra, Cena said the stunt made him
so uneasy that he almost quit movie entirely.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
On her first day of shooting The Force Awakens,
actress Daisy Ridley almost had a panic attack
in the middle of the desert when director
JJ Abrams gave her a note she would never
forget.
Describing her performance as the billion-dollar
franchise's new heroine as “wooden,” the
young actress, who was already terrified of
having Star Wars on her shoulders, almost
walked away from Rey right then and there.
Luckily for everyone, she decided against
it.
The Abyss
For the scene in which Mary Elizabeth Mastrantonio's
character is given CPR, the actress had no
choice but to be pushed, pressed, screamed
at and even slapped by her co-star Ed Harris,
all while lying on a cold, wet metal floor.
So you can't blame her for walking off the
set when she found out a camera had broken
in the middle of the take, meaning they needed
to re-shoot it.
She eventually returned, giving Cameron enough
footage to stretch the scene out to a full
five minutes.
One of the longest scenes of its kind, and
just another extreme case of the blockbuster
director driving his cast to the breaking
point.
Rocky IV
Things got a little too real on the set of
Rocky IV when Dolph Lundgren threw Carl Weathers
across the ring.
Weathers stormed off and refused to return
to set.
Production on the film halted for four days
until Sylvester Stallone was able to convince
Weathers into returning so could Drago finish
putting the future events of Creed in motion.
The French Connection
Director William Friedkin made it well known
that Gene Hackman wasn't his first choice
for the hard-nosed star in critical hit The
French Connection.
Hackman was having second thoughts himself
when he had to wear a Santa costume and tackle
someone - 27 times.
Hackman threatened to leave the film, and
even admitted he almost quit a handful of
times... while accepting his Oscar for Best
Actor.
The Birds
Alfred Hitchcock isn't remembered for treating
his actors well.
And according to actress Tippi Hedren, filming
the final attack scene was the worst week
of her life.
The original plan was to use mechanical birds,
but instead had real birds flung at her by
prop men, while others were actually attached
with string.
On the fifth day of shooting, she collapsed
in tears and a doctor ordered Hitchcock to
give her a week’s rest.
The Shining
As Wendy in The Shining, Shelley Duvall had
what Jack Nicholson has referred to as the
toughest job he’s ever seen an actor have.
She spent most of the film suffering from
exhaustion and dehydrated from the amount
of crying she had to do.
She even began to lose her hair.
The scene where she tries to protect herself
from Jack with a baseball bat still holds
a spot in the Guinness World Records for the
most takes.
They had to shoot it 127 times.
Wayne’s World
Now that the Bohemian Rhapsody scene in Wayne’s
World has become one of the most well known
sing along moments outside of musicals, it’s
impossible to imagine Wayne and Garth banging
their heads to any other song.
Mike Myers felt so strongly about using Queen’s
rock anthem that when the studio pushed for
a cheaper song by Guns and Roses, Myers was
ready to walk.
Since you can’t have Wayne’s World without
Wayne, the song stayed and Bohemian Rhapsody
became a number one hit 17 years after its
initial release.
Chinatown
Faye Dunaway famously clashed with director
Roman Polanski on the set of Chinatown.
When the director refused to give the actress
a bathroom break while shooting the scene
where Jack Nicholson surprises her in her
car,she questioned her involvement altogether.
In the end, it got so bad that Dunaway had
to relieve herself into a coffee cup, which
she then threw in Polanski’s face.
The Fast and The Furious
The initial script for the first Fast and
Furious included a love triangle between Dom,
Letty, and Brian.
Despite having already signed on to play the
character, Michelle Rodriguez fought tooth
and nail to have to this plot element removed,since
it made no sense to cheat on the alpha male
Dom with pretty boy Brian.
She was willing to quit and suffer the consequences
when the filmmakers decided to pump the brakes
on the love triangle, choosing Dom's little
sister, Mia, instead.
It's hard to picture what some of these movies
would have been had the stars walked away,
but what are your favorite stories of actors
pushed to the breaking point?
Let us know in the comments, and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.